ليست ضايفتنا لكنها من اهل البيت كان
سنكون معانا نادين خماش اليوم وتجربتها في
افغانستان قبل عامين مش هقولك اهلا بك ما
انتي معايا
عم نعمل شغلات خارج الصندوق الله الله من
اول ما جينا مع بعض وحتى هلا عم نعمل
مقابله مع بعض طيب نادين الحلو انه كان
عندك فرصه قبل سنه من الان قبل سيطره
طالبان على الحكم كنت في افغانستان قبل
سنه من اليوم
دائما سهام لما بتكوني شاهده على احداث
بعينيك وشاهدتي على فتره زمنيه معينه
فبالتالي لما بتعطي معطيات بتصدري احكام
بتكون نابعه من صدق ونابعه من بناء على
مشاهده لما نحنا رحنا قبل عام تقريبا على
افغانستان قبل سيطره حركه طالبا كانت
الامور طبيعيه خلال عقدين من الزمن نتحدث
عن 20 عاما اول ما توصل سهام البشائر
اول ما بتوصل لمطار حامد كرزاي في كابول
تستقبلك في الامن العام سيدات يعني تخيلي
واجهت افغانستان للعالم عم نحكي وقتها قبل
عام واجهه افغانستان العالم كانت سيدات
على الامن العام بيختموا الجوازات
بيستقبلوكي في ابتسامه اهلا بك في كابول
فبتوصلي انت في العاصمه الافغانيه طبعا
اكيد بده يكون في عندك شويه خوف من النظره
الصور النبطيه البلد مش مستقره يعني كل
حياته بتلاقي انه نساء كانوا موجودين في
كل مكان يعني زي ما انا مثلا هلا هون
عمالي كنت باعمل كيسه كاميرا وراي سيدات
عم بيمشوا كانوا عملهم بتسوق كان مليان
بالنسبه
كانوا حتى المقاهي المقاهي على الموجودين
بيكسره كانوا يشعروا بالامان كان يشعروا
بالراحه زي ما انا شايفه هون انا لابسه
همم خلفك هذا كان تصوير بمعرض هذا معرض
كان اسبوع
فبالتالي كان في كثير دور للمراه
الافغانيه وكانت تريد ان تكون الى جانب
الرجل بمساواه مع الرجل للنهوض في المجتمع
على صعيد اقتصادي وعلى صعيد اجتماعي فهن
انا كنت عمالي بتسوق في معرض هذا معرض
اسبوعي كلها نعمل سيدات نسائي نساء
موجودين بس كمان ملاحظه سهام خصوصا بلحظات
الاخيره والاسابيع الاخيره كان كثير في
عندهم خوف كانوا دايما يخافوا وكان عندهم
نظره رؤيه قويه اكثر من مراكز صنع القرار
والدراسات التي تحدثت عن مستقبل افغانستان
اليوم خصوصا بعد سيطره كانوا يقولوا انه
نحن كان نساء عدو طالبان كانوا خائفين
خائفين مما بعده كانوا يطالبوا انه يا
عالم انقذونا انا بعرف واحده من السيدات
سهام قبلتها افغانستان كانت واحده من اقوى
100 سيده صنفت دوليه هذه السيده كانت تعيش
بكام الحريته والامان وفخوره بنفسها وكان
في سيراتو يعملوا لهم في البرلمان
الافغاني اليوم بعد الحركه هربت وغادرت
الى بلاد اخرى بسبب
على راس قائمه فورس